hey youtubers is Charlie so for my Q&A
today a lot of you asked for a longer
video so I made it 20 questions so it's
just twice as long as I normally do
there were a lot of good ones so I tried
to pick questions that would allow me to
kind of cover everything that you guys
were asking about quick shout out for
the giveaway winners congratulations to
Matty took the infinite draw and serena
yuri you guys all win Amazon gift cards
I'll be contacting you on your channels
for details so be sure to check your
inboxes I'm still gonna be doing Game of
Thrones videos and giveaways every week
but the giveaway will probably just move
to my legend decor videos on Fridays or
Saturdays so let's answer some finale
questions careful for spoilers from the
episode if you haven't seen it yet but
here we go question number one Savage
asks could you comment on judgments
death being a huge change from the books
in the books he just forced sees his
future and it hasn't happened yet on the
show the three-eyed Raven acknowledges
that Jojen knew he was going to die so
they did pay homage to it but it
happened in a slightly different way
that it did in the books generally I
think his death on the show didn't
dramatically change anything that would
have happened in the future
his story was essentially done he was
there to get Brant to the three-eyed
Raven question number two ladies Zelda
asks will we ever see Rickon again yeah
everyone wants to know where trickin go
he just kind of disappeared this season
he's still with OSHA he's not dead or
anything and they have recast the actor
a couple times just because the child
that plays him keeps growing up I expect
to see him at least once next season
without spoiling things from the books
too much he is still a part of the story
but the character that he's associated
with in the books currently is somewhere
else
on the show so they might have to change
the plot a little bit question number
three sax op says I thought the mountain
straight-up died after being poisoned in
the books yes the mountain did die but
it was very very slowly
they just omitted a lot of screaming it
basically took about a week for him to
die what we saw in the show was pretty
close to that they just skipped to the
end question number 4 Jessica asks do
you know what the Bloodraven meant when
he said that bran would fly so really he
was just talking about the warning
ability so like the three-eyed Raven you
know we saw an actual three-eyed Raven
so Brant will continue to just see
through animals eyes so it's really just
a clever turn of phrase a lot of that's
explained in book 5 so if any of you
want to comment on what happens to bran
in that book just please use spoiler
tags in the comments so when he said
bran would fly he was saying
that literally and figuratively question
number five dekappa Soros asks do you
believe in the Robert strong theory so
yes because that's a bit of a book
spoiler I'll just say yes I do believe
that that is a thing question number six
floor and K asks what were the skeletons
rising from the ground so this was just
millions of the White Walkers and the
great other you could think of them like
whites that had just basically lost all
their skin they were reanimated corpses
but specifically their purpose was to
guard that tree or at least to keep the
three-eyed Raven from traveling so they
were there if he ever left the tree
physically so that they could kill him
just because the three-eyed Raven and
the great other are on two sides of that
war question number seven doctor who 50
and Beyond asks is this the last we see
of the Hound so yeah I actually thought
that he was dead the first time I
watched this but then I rewatched it and
there's all those things about the
gravedigger theory the gravedigger
theory is something from the books it
just states that this mystery character
that we don't know a lot about is really
Sandor Clegane in disguise question
number eight Andrey asks where do you
think that Varys interiors are going so
there's actually a couple places that
they could be going along that you know
eastern coast of Essos they could be
going to Pentos which is where Illyrio
Varys friend is living remember we saw
him in season one they could also be
going to Braavos and they could go
straight to marine it would have been a
lot easier to tell if Varys had actually
spoken with one of the captains so we
would have known whether he was speaking
Braavosi or some other language question
number nine okay asks that's actually
pretty awesome name do you think that
Arya will meet Jack and Hegar and
Braavos I definitely think that she's
gonna try and find him she doesn't
really know anyone in Braavos other than
Jack and agar and Syrio Forel but she
doesn't know if either one of them are
still alive the last time she saw Jack
and jugar he changed his face too so if
the show does reintroduce him inside
Braavos he might not have the same face
but it's important to note that unlike
Syrio Forel there's a lot more certainty
that Jack and agar is still alive and
just wearing someone else's face
question number 10 frag kill asks wasn't
Lady Stoneheart going to be in the
finale
wasn't there a teaser poster so I never
saw a teaser poster there was something
that Lena Headey posted but she claimed
that that was her being drunk in Palm
Springs I just think that's kind of
funny just an actor being drunk being
silly Jimmy
Kimmel actually asked her if she got in
trouble for posting that photo and she
said that she didn't know
so she hopes that Dan and Dave don't
kill her next season but Lady Stoneheart
was actually never supposed to be part
of season 4 she wasn't even part of the
story planning so that doesn't mean that
she won't show up in season 5 I know a
lot of you book readers really want to
see her though I wouldn't be totally
upset if they completely cut her out but
it would be a bit of a disappointment
question number 11 NIC ng asks did we
see Jojen warg in his final moments
before he blew up I actually had to
rewatch that scene a couple times
because I had the same thought I think
that's just a reflection of the
pyrotechnics on his eyes the reason the
child of the forest blew his body up was
so that it could not be reanimated as a
white it's really awesome to think about
the idea of Jojen just living out the
rest of his life as an animal somewhere
the show only touched on this briefly
but remember when bran was worried
inside of summer they said that if he
stayed in too long that he would just
forget that he was a person and just
take on this wolf persona so that would
happen to Jojen if he actually did work
out at the last minute he would just
completely become whatever animal he
wore it into question number 12
spandy asks which characters do you
think they'll cut out of the story next
season so I think they'll probably cut
out moon boy a bunch of the Kievan
Lannister stuff and maybe some of the
minor characters in Mereen but largely
all the characters that would be cut out
have already been cut out and there's a
few characters we haven't met yet that I
don't want to talk about just because it
might be a little bit spoilery I know
there's some great joy characters that
everyone really really hopes we see so
I'm gonna wait for some casting news
before I talk about them question number
13 Brian asks why did they change
Tyrians character so much I think you're
just asking about in the black cells
whenever he escaped I think they wanted
to maintain that bond that he had with
Jaime it seems like on a larger level
the changes they've made to the tearing
character have made him seem a lot more
positive in the books he has a lot more
hate inside of him I think as a
consequence of that it'll make it a
little bit easier for his character to
reconcile with Jaime at a future date if
they ever end up meeting up again
question number fourteen flaw Normandie
asks will they ever regain control over
drogon so drogon is essentially just
getting bigger and bigger so he's almost
out of everyone's control I mean he's
not as big si balerion the black dread
but he's always going to be bonded to
Daenerys that doesn't mean that she'll
always have complete control over him
but she will always be
linked to him on a fundamental level so
he will always come back to her I'm
really interested to see how the show
expresses that visually next season
because yes they are linked but he is
pretty wild like he's a wild animal it'd
be like keeping a lion in your house
question number 15 siempre Viva says I
know people don't like brand story as
much but if they ever made children of
the forest spin-off I would donate all
my wigs to charity we're definitely
gonna hold you to that but they are
developing a spin-off show it's not
gonna be a children of the forest story
but george RR martin was signed to a
contract after season 1 of game of
thrones aired HBO gave them a
development deal we don't have any
details on what the spin-off is going to
be or whether it's gonna be a prequel he
did say that it's probably not gonna be
about Robert's rebellion
I'm really hoping whatever it ends up
being that it's like Blackfyre rebellion
or dancing the dragons or some other big
great event in Westeros history question
number 16
Jenny asks do you think that Melisandre
will give us more info on Jon Snow's
true identity I think she knows a lot
about his destiny or at least thinks
that she knows a lot about his destiny I
don't think she knows who his parents
are though regardless of what the show
decides to include from the books those
two characters are gonna have some
really interesting scenes next season
think about the influence that
Melisandre has had on Stannis in the
last couple of seasons I don't think
she's gonna have quite an easy time with
Jon Snow like he's not someone that's
gonna drink the kool-aid right away but
I think that she's gonna spend a lot of
time trying to kind of rope him into
this greater conflict question number 17
Dillon asks which character do you think
has changed the most this season I would
definitely say Ari in the Hound The
Hound has gotten a lot nicer and Ari has
gotten a lot darker
they both had this really awesome
feedback loop of hate it should be noted
that in the hounds final moments he did
start to get a little bit more noble he
was trying to protect aria
or at least he was trying to convince
Brienne that he was trying to protect
aria question number 18 crack okoto
Games asks what's brains supposed to do
now that he's with the three-eyed Raven
so he's just gonna learn more about
green seeing green sight green dreams
all those special powers the Jojen
started to teach him about question
number 19 tribus HD asks what do you
think the best death of the season was
so the best confirmed it the best person
that we saw and we know is dead was
Joffrey obviously just watching him go
totally purple in the face that was
amazing as far as the best unconfirmed
death I would say the Hound
I'd like
the way the hound ended the best but
it's totally possible that he could have
survived that and just gone off
somewhere else and we won't see him
again or at least for a long long time
that is the funny thing about Game of
Thrones unless you see a pile of ashes
or a chopped off head they're not
confirmed dead question number 20 Shia
asks how did Stannis move an army that
big to the wall without running into the
Bolton's so the easy answer is is that
he basically went the long way around
and came in on the north side of the
wall
if you look at Braavos on the map here
he basically just went north and
bypassed all the Bolton's because they
were way down here south of the wall so
the only way someone would have known he
was coming as if a ship had passed them
as they were traveling from Braavos I
know on the show it seemed like a bit of
a deus ex machina but you remember it
was actually several episodes ago that
he got that loan to get the soldiers so
basically right after that happened he
would have gotten that army and
immediately started sailing so he's been
sailing this whole time and one last
bonus Shea question Jaime asks do you
think that Shea was a spy planted by
Tywin this whole time that's actually a
really interesting thought no I don't
think that's the case I think it's just
a coincidence I think it would have been
easier to believe if Tywin had known
about the twincest but I think that's a
good example of people slipping things
by Tywin or him just being blind to
things that are really obvious in front
of his eyes as far as his plans
concerned Tyrion I think he was just
happy to keep Tyrion off to the side out
of trouble I don't think he would have
invested that much time and money into
him so thank you so much for so many
questions guys these delayed Skype
sessions are always so much fun to do
with you so please let me know if you
want me to continue doing Q&A videos in
the future obviously I'm just going to
be doing weekly Game of Thrones videos
so if you really want me to do Q&A I'll
try to keep doing them but as I start
doing more Doctor Who and legend decor
videos it'll be a little bit harder but
worst case scenario I'll just include
questions in the regular bonus videos a
lot of you have asked and yes I'm going
to be doing Game of Thrones videos every
Sunday so if you just found me be sure
to subscribe to get everything and to
all of you guys who've been subscribers
for a long time here are a couple big
shows that are coming this summer that I
want you guys to get ready for coz I'm
gonna be doing videos for them first off
is Teen Wolf season 4 that's premiering
on Monday next week a lot of you asked
me to do weekly videos so I'm going to
do that
there's going to be 12 episodes total
then later this summer is a Legend of
Korra book 3 I know a bunch of you quit
the show during book 2 because you
like it but book 3 is gonna be amazing
so start watching it again it's a
Nickelodeon show for those who don't
know you can find it on iTunes though
it's probably not gonna premiere to July
so you still have a little bit of time
to catch up if you've never watched it
before then Doctor Who series 8 and
Outlander are coming in August you guys
know about Doctor Who but Outlander is
another big series based on a lot of
books I haven't read them yet but I will
be so I'm gonna do at least a video for
that premiere so be sure to catch up on
Doctor Who before that comes and if you
want to read that first Outlander book
if you haven't already I only do videos
for stuff that I think is gonna be
amazing so you guys should check all
those things out but if you have
questions about them just ask me in the
comments my next game of Thrones video
is gonna post Thursday or Friday that's
gonna be my top 10 moments from season
four
right now though you can click here to
catch up on my season 5 predictions and
click here to watch my finale video
thank you so much for watching this is
gonna be an amazing summer so everybody
be sure to give each other a high five
I'll see you guys tonight
thanks
you